et les annonces de jean iv de jean
castex n'ont pas ravi dévié jaune dans
la rue de nouveau aujourd'hui pour
dénoncer les mesures sanitaires donc
mais aussi réclamé comme au début de
leur mouvement à plus de justice sociale
non cortège parisien notre reporter
david khalifa on retrouve tout de suite
mon jour david alors comment ça se passe
actuellement
eh bien écoutez les cortèges qui
contient à peu près plusieurs centaines
de manifestants à s'est élancée de la
place de la bourse pour se rendre à
l'hôpital saint-antoine l'objectif cet
après-midi dénoncé les agissements du
gouvernement concernant cette crise
sanitaire et notamment les déclarations
d'hyères de jean castex 1 sur le projet
de loi concernant le pass vaccinale à
passer vaccinale concert considérée
comme liberticide pour la plupart des
manifestants présents ici est cet
après-midi évier le cortège s'arrête à
plusieurs reprises dans les rues pour
distribuer des tracts aux gens pour les
alerter notamment sur les dangers de la
vaccination que ce soit pour les enfants
mais aussi pour les adultes nour
également au pass sanitaire considéré
lui aussi comme liberticide la plupart
des manifestants présents ici un
considère que la pandémie a renforcé ce
sentiment de déni de la démocratie pour
le gouvernement je vous propose
d'écouter à quelques-uns des
manifestants
là on constate depuis hier et les
interventions de jean castex vraiment
une accélération de la de l'oppression
vaccinale est donc donc là même les gens
qui ont eu le coc vide et qui sont
immunisés au même les gens qui kiffent
on déteste ne pourront plus circuler
librement puisque ça ne va plus être un
pass sanitaire mais impasse vaccinale
donc là on est vraiment dans une
restriction des libertés jamais vu donc
donc c'est un scandale et donc j'appelle
j'appelle les gens à prendre conscience
de la gravité de ce qui se passe et à
bouger réagir quoi parce que là on est
vraiment dans quelque chose d'inédit il
n'y a pas de colère particulier en tout
cas pas pas plus qu'on en avait
précédemment puisque c'est la
confirmation de ce qu'on pensait depuis
toujours politique totalitaire parce
qu'il n'a rien de sanitaires mais qui
est un pass totalitaire et maintenant
vaccinale les légendes donc le mot
résistance à la bouche mais il ne faut
pas le galvauder pour j'appelle tous les
gilets déjà et tous mes compatriotes
tous tous mes congénères même au pad au
delà même de mes compatriotes à résister
à empêcher ce cette entreprise
criminelle
parmi cette contestation contre
l'obligation vaccinale les
revendications elle s inscrit dans la
continuité à pour les gilets jaunes
voilà quelques tensions entre
manifestants comme vous pouvez le voir
sur ces images de baptiste gosselin mais
être rapidement apaisée à puisque à
plusieurs reprises comme vous le disait
il s'essaye à un de sensibiliser les
personnes des passants à la vaccination
obligatoire certains le prennent bien
d'autres le prennent un peu moins bien
et la cena rencontre c'est un
manifestant à ce qui donne lieu à
quelques tensions mais très vite apaisée
le cortège est encadré par un dispositif
de sécurité plutôt minime par rapport
aux autres rassemblements en tout cas la
manifestation poursuit sa route inverse
le point final du parcours l'hôpital est
ce un temps avec un objectif clair je
vous le disais un dénoncer cette
obligation vaccinale et les agissements
du gouvernement là durant cette crise
sanitaire
merci david pour toutes ces précisions